bonsoir et bienvenue dans ça vous
regarde ravi de vous trouvez ça y est
les jeux sont faits la campagne
présidentielle s'achève ce soir à minuit
macron le pen le pen matheron cette
affiche dont les français ne voulaient
pas su finalement reproduite mais est ce
vraiment là même qu'il y a 5 ans acte
hôtels de deux france irréconciliables
après l'élection qu'elle trace les fera
cette drôle de campagne auprès des
français et comment nos voisins
européens nous regarder nous comprenne à
l'heure du soir va se poser toutes ces
questions dans un instant dans notre
grand débat avec nos invités notre grand
témoin ce soir et diplomate c'est lui
qui a organisé au péril de sa vie
l'évacuation en quinze jours des civils
français d'afghanistan et des afghans
qui ont travaillé pour la france au
moment de la chute de kaboul 15 jours
décisifs qui ont suivi la prise du
pouvoir par les talibans qu'il raconte
dans un livre l'ambassadeur de france en
afghanistan david martinon est avec nous
ce soir voilà pour le programme hashtag
cbr n'oubliez pas c'est parti
[Musique]
et bienvenue à vous chers
téléspectateurs 51 jours de campagne
pour emmanuel macron 380 pour marine le
pen c'est le quotidien l'opinion qui a
fait le calcul le même duel qu'il ya
cinq ans à une france de plus en plus
fracturées que dit cette campagne de
notre pays c'est la question qu'on va se
poser ce soir avec nos quatre invités
quatre journalistes au profil bien
distincts bien différent bonsoir yves
thréard soient ravis de vous accueillir
éditorialiste au figaro catherine tricot
bienvenus directrice des éditions de la
revue regards brice couturier bonsoir
ravis de vous accueillir sur ce plateau
producteur à france culture journaliste
essayiste votre dernier ouvrage hockey
milliner aussi là tout se mérite
attention montre en quête d'un baby
boomer sur la génération web c'est aux
éditions de l'observatoire la
journaliste allemande brita sundberg qui
dirige le bureau du spiegel à paris va
nous rejoindre dans un tout petit
instant mais on ouvre le bal avec vous
stéphane blakowski bonsoir mon sens
mieux je veux être la cause là il doubla
quoi en forme de bilan ce soir qu'avez
vous retenu de cet entre deux tours je
range mes affaires si le bilan vous le
disiez donc je suis tombé sur des
archives papier d'un mois et demi dans
les échos qui nous disait quoi mais que
tous les autres gains certes de macron
l'accusait de se défiler donc voyez à
l'époque on se disait il aux rilos pas
descente sur le ring d'ailleurs s'il
descend sur le ring il va se faire
cogner sans son bilan il a jamais se
relever bon finalement il est descendu
sur le ring puis la mer plutôt en forme
notre candidat président d'air cet
esprit un peu combatifs ils voulaient
l'affiché dans son avant dernière
journée de campagne en allant voir les
électeurs de jean luc mélenchon en seine
saint denis
moi je vais ce qui verra les
allées
[Musique]
il a la confiance macro ont dit non je
ne tape pas trop fort sinon je vais
l'état d un coût normal tristement il
n'était pas dans la même catégorie mais
il y croit et on sent que il aurait bien
voulu mettre le pen chaos qui
s'installerait alors dans le débat il
l'a mis dans les cordes
mois myriam seriez pas en train de filer
la métaphore pugilistique
ferme gaiement dans les cordes il a du
punch macron mais marine elle encaisse
c'est à dire qu'il doit il rêvait
peut-être une victoire par ko il doit se
contenter en fait d'une victoire aux
points regardez c'est dans le
l'excellent journal du matin le figaro
qui publiait sarsgaard et 56% des
français ont trouvé mâcon plus
convaincant certes mais ses 16 points de
moins que renommés 17 et donc ils sont
seulement 44% avoir trouvé même loupé le
plus convaincant droid mais c'est seul
point de plus qu'en 2010 est donc même
décrété une victoire aux points de
macron il a quand même perdu beaucoup
beaucoup de points de permis en même
temps avant dimanche est là elle a du
retard dans les sondages marine le pen
une dizaine de points dans les sondages
alors oui mais là désolé je suis désolé
de dire ça mais les français les plus
pauvres ne peuvent s'en prendre qu'à
elle-même myriam parce que les français
les plus pauvres les moins diplômés ceux
qui votent pour marine le pen
normalement c'est eux qui ont un grand
espoir de changements qu'on renverse
khattab et le problème c'est que c'est
justement eu les mêmes les français les
plus pauvres les moins diplômés qui
s'abstiennent le plus donc marine le pen
c'est ce qu'elle fait est leur double
appel aux urnes quoi on écoute et ceux
qui sont tentés par une stérile
abstentions je leur dis si vous n'allez
pas la politique c'est la politique qui
viendra à vous qui vous rattrapera avec
patron qui vous maltraitera pour des
années encore à quoi sert-il de crier
partout macron d'émission pendant trois
jours vous pouvez le congédier
ça veut dire que pour vous rien n'est
joué elle a encore une chance de
l'emporter mais je dirais même plus
myriam elle a déjà gagné amont et bien
comment ça elle a fait 34 % la dernière
fois et ça m'étonnerait qu'elle fasse
moins donc elle va gagner quoi des
points seulement à gagner des millions
de voix si on s'en tient aux sondages
d'ailleurs ce matin et est sûre si news
et réfléchissaient déjà un petit peu aux
législatives en se disant que si son
parti cette fois n'était pas largement
représentés à l'assemblée comme ça a été
le cas dans la dernière mandature il
devrait comme un petit problème
démocratique en écoute nous sommes
devenus une démocratie défaillante est
un des éléments c'est évidemment que des
courants de pensée qui sont extrêmement
forts et qui représente des millions de
nos compatriotes ne sont pas
correctement
représentés à l'assemblée nationale qui
est le lieu où l'on vote la loi commune
et ça c'est un problème majeur
d'ailleurs encore une fois emmanuel
macron le sait puisqu'il s'était engagé
à mettre en oeuvre la proportionnelle et
qu'il a rompu sa promesse
attention à pas enjamber le scrutin
avant les législatives ya dimanche et le
résultat vous dire que emmanuel macron
pareils indices qu'ils se projettent un
minimum quand même ce matin il était sur
france inter vous avez peut-être
entendre qu'avec son programme chiffré
en milliards puis réussit une réflexion
sur une nouvelle manière de diriger le
pays un petit peu flou cette nouvelle
méthode donc il nous parle mais ce qu'on
a créé retenir c'est que jupiter c'est
fini tôt on écoute
il faudra si les françaises et les
français me font confiance rénover plus
en profondeur la manière d'exercer la
fonction présidentielle et que je sens
bien qu'il ya un décalage entre le
renouvellement politique que j'ai
incarné et le classicisme de l'exercice
de la fonction donc voilà j'ai pas beau
c'est ma conclusion il ya plein d dit en
riant mon avis sont pleins de trucs à
dire je m'en vais merci beaucoup c'est
vrai qu'il ya beaucoup de sujets
différents dans le papier de stéphane on
va commencer par votre regard sur ces 15
derniers jours quelle analyse vous fait
de cet entre-deux-tours ya beaucoup de
choses qui ont bougé qui a pris le plus
de risques finalement dans cet entre
deux tours qui a tenté de convaincre un
électorat le plus large possible puisque
c'est l'objectif du deuxième tour il
traire d'après moi c'est plutôt le
présidence c'est à dire c'est emmanuel
macron en faisant cette sortie à
marseille sur l'écologie qui était quand
même assez peu présente de son programme
et en marchant vraiment sur les traces
de jean luc mélenchon en reprenant même
d expression de jean luc mélenchon qui
essaient de la programmation écologique
l'année de la tête violations écologique
même qui correspond assez peu d'ailleurs
à l'état d'esprit de 2 emmanuel macron
mais c'était un esprit je pense qu'il a
beaucoup évolué depuis des années et des
années mais donc c'est quand même
emmanuel macron qui a pris ce risque
parce que je sais pas il avait comme un
un un doute probablement sur son duel
avec madame le pen en se disant j'ai pas
fait beaucoup campagne en première
partie de 2,2 justement de
présidentielle ne pas faire campagne
c'était aussi une façon de faire
campagne si on comprend ici on me suit
mais enfin bon il avait
fait drapeau puis après ça c'est assez
peu au contact des français et donc là
il essaie de se rattraper et
programmatiquement il est allé à mon
avis plus loin dans la main tendue à
l'électorat de jean luc mélenchon que
madame le pen qui est quand même quoi
qu'on dise
assez éloignées
sur beaucoup de sujets de du leader de
la france 1 sont mis d'accord avec cette
analyse 4 est celui qui s'est le plus
engagé c'est certain mais faut dire
qu'il n'avait pas fait grand chose
jusque là donc il a pensé qu'il
suffirait de faire une conférence de
presse pour leurs portes pour nous
emballer il a il a dû quand même
constaté que certes il a augmenté par
rapport à 2017 mais finalement il le
fait grâce si on peut dire à
l'effondrement de valérie pécresse et
qu'il avait une france divisée en 3 ce
qui est quand même l'événement la
nouveauté de cette situation a créé 22 %
dans le monde en deux blocs on n'a pas
la gauche et la droite cette fois ci on
a véritablement à bloc on va en parler à
table on aura même le quatrième bloc
bloc abstentionnistes et donc il a dû
quand même y aller et en effet sa fin la
mesure phare qui l'avait mis en avant la
retraite à 65 ans il s'est quand même
rendu compte et dans les urnes et aux
comptes allait bouger dans les trains
entre oui alors je sais pas s'il a
vraiment beaucoup bougé mais en tout cas
il arrondit les angles on va dire
bonsoir bergues merci d'être là vous
diriger le bureau parisien du du chp
eagle à paris on a besoin de votre votre
regard de deux journalistes allemands de
sur cette campagne même question qu'est
ce qui vous a qu'est ce qui vous a
marqué on a l'impression quand même que
la stratégie de la rue diabolisation de
marine le pen a joué à plein quand on
regarde le front républicain
des barrages des artistes des sportifs
des syndicats des anciens présidents de
la république à voter pour emmanuel
macron et contre marine le pen est ce
que ça c'était aussi la stratégie d'
emmanuel macron l'étiquette d'extrême
droite géré collé cette étiquette
qu'elle récuse est-ce que ça c'était
payant ou au contraire marine le pen qui
elle a voulu insister sur sa relation
aux français qui souffrent a marqué des
points je crois que les deux ont marché
dans les deux camps
comme marine le pen a très tôt mis comme
tout le monde
vu sur le sol sur le sujet du pouvoir
d'achat évidemment elle a changé avec
grand succès une partie de son image
et de l'autre côté maintenant pendant
les derniers jours en
les efforts de faire barrage sont de
plus en plus visible et en même temps je
trouve que enfin vu d'une lapointe le
point de vue d'une allemande
le débat et les échos après ce débat moi
ce qui m'étonne c'est que la france
parle d'une façon très intense est ce
que le président était arrogant ou par
un gant moi je trouve qu après ce débat
on aurait pu parler de bien autre chose
je trouvais que ce soit c'est en
arrogance est injustifiée je trouve que
c'est pas c'est pas cette fois le sujet
c'est à dire qu'on a à faire avec une
candidate qu'on savait avant mais on a
bien vu pendant cependant ce débat tu
veux complètement changer l'europe qui
veut changer les contrats européens qui
veut se retirer
qui veut qu veut qu'il veut baisser le
budget français par rapport la
commission qui veut complètement changé
les relations avec l'allemagne qui veut
mettre stop à réau au projet en commun
de la défense afin qu'il veut une europe
qui est totalement différente qui venait
allemagne qui est totalement différente
et qui veut mettre sous amendes des
musulmanes en france vivent en france
quand elle porte un foulard donc
pénaliser une partie de la population
française et les français parlent comme
sujet de l'arrogance les opposants à
emmanuel macron daguerre oui mais la
presse revient à bien repris enfin les
journaux ont bien repris ça il n'y a pas
je trouve à la hauteur vous trouvez non
journalisme non journalisme en général
c'est parce que je ne
sais vraiment pas puis y ait des flandes
écoute avec cette mine affligée
d'emmanuel macron écoutant son sa
concurrente ou était trop je trouve que
c'est se porter trop sur les apparences
et non pas assez sur le contenu brice
couturier votre regard sur cet
entre-deux-tours ces quinze jours je
suis exactement du même avis que ma
consoeur allemande je pense qu'on s'est
focalisée sur des détails insignifiants
et que les grands enjeux n'ont pas été
réels évoquez je veux dire on a commencé
cette campagne en parlant de quoi de
l'immigration et de l'insécurité ça fait
monter zemmour beaucoup ensuite son avis
qu'on a vu que la campagne a dévié vers
d'autres sujets de préoccupation qui
était en gros les retraites le pouvoir
d'achat puis tout récemment
l'environnement honnêtement c'est pas le
problème le problème c'est qu'on est en
train on est au bord de la guerre en
europe on est déjà dans la guerre
puisque la russie considère que nous
sommes en guerre avec elle qu'elle est
en guerre avec le temps moi j'attendais
un chef de guerre j'attendais un chef de
guerre qui nous qui nous indique que
nous allons rentrer dans des difficultés
économiques très grande et non pas
quelqu'un qui suivent marine le pen dans
cdm dans sa démagogie électoraliste en
nous promettant des prestations sociales
dont nous n'avons pas les moyens
c'est ridicule de promettre aux gens une
retraite à 60 ans gratis dans cette
campagne sans vision
hier le président lui-même s'est trouvé
en bringué dans une affaire de de
surenchère de promesses électorales
impossible à tenir qui vont provoquer
après son élection probable des
mouvements sociaux graves parce que nous
allons rentrer dans une période
extrêmement difficile dans une période
d'inflation de stagflation prolongée
nous allons rentrer dans une période d'
économie de guerre dans lequel la
demande est stupidement stimuler alors
que l'offre ne va pas suivre donc pour
des raisons économiques nous allons
rentrer dans une période très difficile
dans une période qui va créer de grandes
frustrations et c'était vraiment pas le
moment de faire des promesses
électorales donc ça manquait au fond
pédagogie sur la dureté des temps
je vais ajouter comme brice un autre
dossier à ce dossier
et c'est compliqué sur la guerre en
ukraine c'est celui de ce qui se passe
en chine avec le co vide et vous avez vu
qu'ils ont abordé ce sujet avec une
toute autre technique que la nôtre qui
risque de mettre plein l'économie
mondiale ce que la chine étant un des
moteurs économiques du monde avec cette
histoire de zéro co vide ou d une
suspicion ferme tout
et l'allemagne surtout dépendantes et si
l'allemagne est à l'arrêt nous on est à
l'allemagne on est on est à la rue ça
c'est vrai que personne en a parlé on en
parle très peu alors ça c'est une chose
deuxième chose je trouve pas que le
président de la république et fait des
promos dvd des promesses inconsidérées
parce qu'il n'est pas allé sur le
terrain de marine le pen il n'a pas
concédé à marine le pen on va arrêter il
a gagné il a plié le match il y avait
mais c'était du 90% contre contre 10%
la portance et le contenu et on sait
très bien que madame le pen et c'est
pour ça que je pense que les français
contrairement à ce qu'on dit sont
beaucoup plus raisonnables et beaucoup
plus conscients de la situation ne vont
pas faire une embardée qui fait qu' on
sera dans un résultat serré ce ce
dimanche mais sur le contenu on va on va
arrêter de dire ce débat a montré
la compétence après faut la volonté et
la possibilité de tenir ses promesses et
de l'autre l'incompétence on va le dire
la démagogie et il faut arrêter que la
presse ait said entretenir un suspense
qui n'existe pas qui n'existe pas en
allemagne ont gagné l'élection dans le
débat
qui disent or ils sont quasiment à
égalité me voir était d'accord katrina
tricot je crois que en effet il n'ya pas
probablement pas beaucoup de suspense
pour le résultat de ce week-end de
dimanche mais néanmoins je ne crois pas
que la question était simplement
question de compétence et d'incompétence
je pense qu'il y avait un débat
d'orientation politique et que je moi je
pense vous avez vu vous les orgas et on
peut dénombrer 2,2 à ballack à ceux de
l'un de l'autre et de l'absent c'est à
dire que ce qu' il ya eu trois
propositions qui sont qui ont émergé
dans cette campagne et je pense que
l'enjeu était de convaincre
politiquement de l'orientation proposée
par emmanuel macron lui c'est ça qu'ils
devaient faire il devait pas simplement
montrer sa technicité dans les chiffres
réels
elle n'a pas simplement était moi je
crois qu'elle était fiancée à partir de
l'europe qu'on l'a vu absolument on l'a
vu à partir de l'engin mais même sur la
question sociale on voit bien que c'est
pas je dis rien hein qui dit on va faire
des progrès sociaux et ce avec les
salariés qui vont payer elle elle dit on
va faire des progrès sociaux et c'est
des immigrés qui vont payer et jean luc
mélenchon disait on va faire des progrès
sans laisser des riches qui vont payer
ça faisait quand même trois propositions
assez radicalement différente mais je
veux dire c'est quand même bien une
question qui était d'abord une question
d'orientation politique de type de
société que l'on voulait voir et que je
crois que la question s'est dessinée
soit officialisée oui et je pense que
c'est donc le problème de la compétence
et d'incompétence n'était pas central
quand en revanche la question du méprise
je vous disais que c'était des détails
insignifiants
moi je crois que c'était pas tout
ajustement 6 à arraisonner c'est que
c'était pas insignifiant c'est dire que
des il ya un certain nombre de deux
français qui se sont sentis au cours de
ce quinquennat qui se sont sentis mal
traités par par le président et que donc
ce n'était pas insignifiant si on
considère que la question est de savoir
qui est la ressource je vous ressources
du pays voilà quelles sont les forces
vives justement je vous propose pas de
les entendre ou pas les français parce
que c'est intéressant de savoir si
effectivement il ya deux france qui
s'oppose à travers ce duel de deux
finalistes on va les écouter les
électeurs tentés par l'une ou par
l'autre clément père vos examens gamins
ont suivi deux députés sortants en
campagne un élu du rassemblement
national près de lens dans le pas de
calais et puis une autre dans le tarn en
occitanie reportage
cette france votent massivement marine
le pen
dans l'ancien bassin minier du pas de
calais la candidate du rassemblement
national est arrivé largement en tête au
premier tour à avion dans
l'agglomération de lens
elle a fait 39 %
nous sommes le lendemain du débat
emmanuel blé riz jeune député du rnd
vient écouter la droite du terrain à
pâques pour la présidentielle
vous avez des bailleurs j'aurais pensé
j'ai pensé qu'au xviie qui mord vu
s'énerver quand même c'était du très
énervé
ses mains peu un peu tremblante alpes il
lui a coupé la parole et une fois c'est
pas honnête on est vraiment j'ai croisé
des dizaines de personnes notion il faut
marcher tourner le sort se profile un de
président afghan
c'est du mépris ça s'est même élevée
mais en fait si l'âge il pendant trois
heures comme il a jugé que le peuple
français pendant cinq ans le président
arrogant c'est l'angle d'attac désormais
mais ça ne suffit pas toujours
avec lui avec lui quand même assez vrai
pour la retraite à 65 ans
évidemment monsieur un tract pour la
présidentielle marine le pen éléments
venant à vous comporter avec les écouter
même jour même heure dans le tarn à
graulhet ici aussi marine le pen est
arrivé en tête talonné de près par jean
luc mélenchon mais marie christine dardy
jouclas députés en marche ne désespère
pas et hier soir au débat elle a été
bien un porte-à-faux
jusqu'à minuit et bien alors vous en
avez pensé quoi vous avez vu tout ce
qu'ils proposent est proposé de faire
c'est vrai mais c'est vrai mais c'est
pour ça tu voulais me tall et c'est pour
ça que je vous rappelle qu'on avait dit
qu on supprimerait la taxe d'habitation
on l'a fait qu'on avait dit combien
seraient les deux premières tranches
d'impôts qu'on l'a fait et que les
feuilles se baissent aussi non mais
attends d'électricité grâce aussi alors
le grand steeple ch aussi mais ça vous
le voyez pour un voyage dimanche dernier
vous avez voté macro mais aussi et ben
ça va vous surprendre mais oui mais
maintenant ça va surprendre parce j'ai
passé ma vie à voter pour arlette
laguiller ménagers comme et votez pour
pour le père macron parce que d'abord il
est très joli garçon qu'est ce qui vous
c'est passionnant mais
le fond du fond cependant une ukraine je
sais bien mais ça c'est le président qui
sait un recul de l'udc fans
d'ukraine pouvoir d'achat stature
présidentielle
ces grands thèmes ont animé du nord au
sud de la france une campagne qui
s'achève ce soir à minuit
atteint s'en sortent portage est
intéressant avec de france vous diriez
ou pas non moi je pense que les choses
sont beaucoup plus compliquées que sar
quoi parce que les fractures sont
multiples il ya la fracture
effectivement territoriale entre les
villes les campagnes il ya la fracture
générationnelle on l'a vu avec ce vote
le vote jeunes qui plus tôt pour
mélenchon le vote des aînés qui plus tôt
pour me le président sortant vous avez
une fracture l'éternel fracture élites
contre contre peuple vous avez la
fracture des diplômes vous avez enfin
vous avez multiples fractures et je
pense pas que voilà la france puisse se
résumer à ce qu'on veut bien dire est la
preuve qu entre ces différents camps
c'est différent tracker on peut encore
se parler ou pas mais bien sûr qu'on
peut se parler il faut aussi je pense
raison garder on n'est pas au bord de la
guerre civile on est avec dans un pays
qui est en colère en colère des kits une
colère qui est une colère peut-être
scène d'ailleurs est là prête ou des
élections c'est fait pour ça c'est fait
pour exprimer sa colère et c'est heureux
que ça puisse se faire et c'est au
président de la république et c'est pour
ça qu'il faut se donner un président de
la république qui soit à la hauteur et
qui ne soit pas dans la démagogie c'est
très important parce que vous savez que
c'est toujours comme ça que ça commence
et que ça finit mal dans la démagogie il
faut être avec un président de la pluie
qui soit à la hauteur de la mission
qu'on lui confie c'est qu'on est un pays
éruptif et que depuis si vous reprenez
l'histoire de la vème république aucun
président de la république tous les
présidents de la république ont été
obligés de se colleter la rue au bout de
quelque temps reconnaissait que pour
cela
vous vous appuyez y compris dans une
crise de croissance qui était celle du
général de gaulle trois ans après son
élection au suffrage universel direct
est bienvenue mais 68 moi j'aimerais
avoir votre regard sur cette affiche
est-ce que c'est exactement la même
qu'il ya cinq ans évidemment les
protagonistes sur les mêmes et on évolue
en 50 mots rien sortant qui est un bilan
et puis il ya un nouveau positionnement
quand même de de marine le pen huit
français sur dix rejeté cette revanche
annoncé sondages et lab pour bfm tv du
12 février du 12 février et pourtant
c'est c'est la même est ce que c'est le
signe au fond
qui a plus de rejet de l'adhésion et on
en arrive là où est ce que c'est le
signe au fond que finalement même si
c'est les mêmes personnes s'est pas
exactement la même offre à will look
c'est le casting dont on ne voulait pas
et qu'on a donc il ya une certaine
déception de la part d'une partie de la
population maintenant il faut voir
qu'effectivement vous aviez vous le
suggérez y est c'est pas la même marine
le pen elle a enlevé de son programme
tout ce qui était le plus aberrant
disons tout ce qui nous faisait sortir
de l'union européenne et qui risquait de
lui voter en particulier la clientèle
âgée celle qui a des retraites et qui
n'a pas du tout envie de les voir fondre
moyennant quoi son programme si vous le
regardez d'à peu près sur le plan
économique vous voyez que il nous mène à
l'inflation c'est une évidence donc pour
les retraités ça serait pas du tout une
bonne affaire ils ont compris qu'ils
n'ont pas voté pour elle
les
rassure davantage que économiquement il
tient la route c'est tout quoi mais
voilà on a on a un casting dont on ne
voulait pas et du coup moi je bous
craint beaucoup ça provoque une
frustration énorme qui se traduisent en
effet dans la rue puisque le paysage
politique a été totalement au la table a
été renversé et que l'on se retrouve non
pas avec trois blocs dont pas avec deux
blocs mais avec 3 on a effectivement un
bloc populiste ne peut pas mettre
l'extrême gauche à l'extrême droite dans
le du même côté et d'ailleurs une époque
quand on voit mélenchon qui dit qu'il
veut être premier ministre des mets de
de marine le pen voit bien que ça se
terminerait dans la rue par la guerre
civile parce qu il est bien évident que
les orientations en particulier en
matière d'immigration de marine le pen
présidente et de marine le pen pro-russe
avec mélenchon à matignon ça se
terminerait très très mal ça sera une
situation de double pouvoir à peu près
insurrectionnel jeu probable si je peux
c'est une des raisons pour lesquelles
les français connaîtront dans un pays
avec un système avec voilà bipartisans
malgré tout enfin en tout cas il ya deux
places à la fin qu'est ce que ça donne
comment on va pouvoir combiner ça c'est
trois blocs et est-ce qu'il va falloir
de toute façon quel que soit le
vainqueur gouverner autrement très vite
rassemblées à l'assemblée nationale dans
le gouvernement quand même ces trois
blocs s'assigne quand même un échec pour
notre pays et notre démocratie parce
qu'avant on avait gauche droite et
maintenant on à gauche droite extrême
droite donc ça veut quand même dire
gauche extrême droite voulait bien moi
je suis
radical non jean luc mélenchon fait 22%
et le total des gauches fait 30% ça veut
dire que plus des deux tiers des
électeurs de gauche ont voté pour jean
luc mélenchon à moins de penser que
toute la gauche est passé à l'extrême
gauche et ça c'est une
je pense que la jeunesse ah non je pense
que jean luc mélenchon c'est ça très
radical dans ses propositions mais vous
savez il ya eu une expression paravent
qui était réformiste radical et je pense
que jean luc mélenchon est un réformiste
radon maduro et non pas comme maduro je
pense que c'est quelqu'un qui est
d'ailleurs très étatiste qui est assez
fidèle de ce point de vue à la tradition
socialiste dont il est issu il a été
quand même longue de longues années
dirigeants et puis ministre de du parti
socialiste et et on retrouve cette cette
volonté de gouverner et cette relative -
que je trouve pas complètement la
boutique lisicki les pensées pour deux
grands partis on en avait deux ou trois
semaines comment faire rentrer ça va
être peut-être obligé quand même
argumenté un petit peu plus et à ne pas
faire simplement une majorité qui impose
to address de l'opposition
pas la parole trop longtemps mais madame
le pen là pour le coup elle a raison il
faut revoir le système je vous revoir
nos institutions c'est certain robin le
mans et on peut passer à trio n'était
c'est ce qui va être fait en premier oui
alors on sait et on dit ça n'intéresse
pas du tout la population ça paraît de
la cuisine alors que le pouvoir d'achat
est à l'ordre du jour que la sécurité
d'un horizon mais il va falloir y passer
quand même parce que cette fragmentation
de la population cette fragmentation de
l'offre politique il va falloir quand
même la considérer pour qu'elle soit
visible dans l'hémicycle de l'assemblée
nationale et donc il va falloir d'une
façon ou d'une autre corrigiez notre
système d'élection de nos députés et à
sainte berthe vous la journée tellement
ça doit vous parler un la culture du
compromis des coalitions la
représentativité au fond de chaque
courant politique y compris dans
l'exécutif évidemment dans le législatif
vous sentez qu'on est prêt nous les
français à ça ou pas je sais pas si vous
êtes prêts mais il me semble que vous
avez tout intérêt
enfin on a parlé de la colère qu'est ce
que la raison de la colère parce que
qu'est-ce qui est la raison pour
l'abstention aussi que les gens ont
l'impression que n'importe qui le votent
ou qui ils votent aussi le vent aux
élections non ça ne change pas ça ne
change pas et se voit il se voit pas
représenté
nous en allemagne n'a totalement comme
vous le savez un autre système est
maintenant n'importe que sera le
résultat moi je suis toujours prudent de
dire avant les élections ce que surtout
après les années qu'on a passé comme ce
que sera le résultat mais
si c'est si c'est emmanuel macron il va
ya voir si on prend les résultats du
premier tour autour de 70% qui n'ont pas
voté pour lui par conviction c'est 70%
de français sont laissés de côté dans
dans l'offre politique
politiquement qu'est ce qu'on peut faire
dans le système institutionnel actuel
qui vous fait entrer des ministres c'est
ça il ya deux chats d'agos très la
droite qu'est ce que vous pourriez
regarder le modèle allemand et vous en
inspirer et évidemment élargir le
gouvernement avec des ministres qui
viennent d'autres horizons d'autres pas
d'autres partis ou de la société civile
ont changé récemment d'un système
politique
dans un deuxième temps il faut il faut
c'est vrai que c'est un scandale enfin
je donne pas très souvent raison à
marine le pen mais c'est un scandale
démocratique d'avoir tant de voir mais
des millions de voir et que 7 8 sièges à
l'assemblée c'est donc c'est normal que
les gens se sentent pas représentés et
la culture de la discussion de la
négociation de la du compromis c'est en
allemagne c'est un
vertueux une vertu en vertu d une vertu
elle est si c'est vu comme une faiblesse
et je crois que l'un la france à
a des progrès à faire mais ce que vous
je vois bien que tout le monde va
vouloir la représentation
proportionnelle le plus vite possible
pour que ce soit une rue n'a semblé plus
représentatives et qu'on va vouloir
affaiblir les pouvoirs de l'exécutif sur
le modèle allemand oui non combat je
mets en garde quand même les gens en
france nous allons vers une période je
le disais de crise très grave
international on ne sait pas à quel
moment le conflit en ukraine va pas
déborder sur l'ensemble de l'europe vers
d'autres pays de l'otan à ce moment là
nous aurons besoin à la tête à la tête
de l'état d'un chef de guerre très fort
disposant de pouvoirs exécutifs très
grand et capable de prendre des
décisions rapides quand on voit comment
les chanceliers les chancelière
allemande chaque fois qu'on discute avec
le présent d'appeler les français du
moment qui leur dit nous avons abouti à
un compromis et la chancelière répond ah
il faut que je concède que le bundestag
a il faut je vois la claque cour de
karlsruhe parce que mes minent la
coalition sera peut-être pas d'accord il
faut que je vois dans mon gouvernement
qui est d'accord qu'il n'y ait pas de
prise en mains publiques dit attendez
moi j'ai pris une décision
le système le système serait le même
historique sur la question militaire ils
ont été capables de faire une volte face
et surtout c'est qu'on ne voit pas
comment on peut gouverner une société
aussi d'abord éclaté et aussi finalement
instruite et politisée que la nôtre sans
l'associer moi je leur geste de jeunes
eux ça ne me paraît pas possible d'aller
comme ça de façon autoritaire d'une
certaine manière avec un chef de guerre
quand bien même il ya des moments où il
faut prendre des décisions rapides c'est
quand même pas l'essentiel de la vie de
notre société il faut un churchill alors
dans la suite de cette discussion pour
voir fort churchill pouvoir démocratique
à coalition à l'allemande je vous
soumettre une enquête ipsos est
exactement là la suite de cette
conversation sur ce qu'on a appelé le
désenchantement des français vis-à-vis
des politiques la fatigue démocratique
certains mêmes parlent de ressentiment
démocratique plus d'un français sur deux
estime que l'élection ne changera rien à
leur vie c'est signé marco pommier puis
on continue juste un
désenchantement des français à deux
jours du second tour de la
présidentielle
l' enquête d'ipsos sopra steria 50 % des
citoyens estiment que leur situation
personnelle se dégradera si emmanuel
macron est réélu même constat du côté de
marine le pen très grande majorité de
français a le sentiment que la situation
économique du pays s'est dégradée que
leur propre situation en termes de
pouvoir d'achat par exemple s'est
dégradée aussi au cours des cinq
dernières années et il n'y a pas le
sentiment là qu' aucun des deux
candidats qualifiés pour le second tour
sera à même d'apporter un réel
changement qui pourra améliorer la
situation
résultat l'abstention s'annonce
importante dimanche seuls 69% des
français sont certains d'aller voter un
chiffre qui cache des disparités selon
l'âge 57 % des jeunes de 18 à 24 ans se
déplaceront contre 82% t 70 ans et plus
autre enseignement la perception des
français sur les deux finalistes malgré
ses efforts pour adoucir son image
57% pensent encore que la candidate du
rassemblement national est un danger
pour la république
points faibles chez emmanuel matheron
son étiquette de président des riches
pour 72% des français il défend avant
tout les intérêts des catégories
privilégiées
le président sortant qui inspire
davantage confiance que sa concurrente
sur la guerre en ukraine où
l'environnement marine le pen elle
paraît plus crédible sur l'immigration
où le pouvoir d'achat ce qui est certain
c'est qu'ils emmanuel macron est perçu
davantage comme ayant l'étoffé d'un
président de la république ce qui est
quand même un avantage pour lui ce
marine le pen a d'autres qualités qui
sont ceux notamment sa capacité à
prendre l'épreuve de français puis sa
volonté surtout de changer les choses en
france mais d'après cette enquête c'est
bien emmanuel macron qui remporterait
l'élection dimanche avec 56 % des
suffrages contre 44% pour marine le pen
une des clés de ce scrutin c'est
l'abstention on sent bien que les
français se disent ça ne sert à rien de
voter il ya une forme de vanité du mode
doit pas pour tout le monde mais quand
même cette proportion là elle augmente
et on le voit chaque enquête on se
demande même si l'abstention va être
plus forte que au premier tour est ce
que c'est la clé de ce scrutin et donc
voilà il pour construire continuer la
discussion comment faire pour ramener
les gens est ce que la réponse mais
qu'institutionnel non alors si laquelle
nos scrutins du scrutin c'est la clé de
notre avenir et vous savez on peut
bricoler tout ce qu'on veut je pense que
cette participation elle ne reviendra
que le jour où on aura et bien mis je ne
sais pas comment mais c'est par
l'éducation qu'on peut arriver à en
verser ducation civique l'éducation au
vote général l'autorité l'autorité de ne
pas aller voter c'est refuser l'autorité
ne pas aller voter c'est refuser de
jouer collectif parce que quel est le
problème nous étions dans des sociétés
l'allemagne la france et toutes les
sociétés du monde occidental chacun dans
un projet collectif ce projet collectif
éclaté avec les nouveaux modes de vie et
nous nous sommes dans un dans le royaume
de l'individualisme aujourd'hui doudou
d'ailleurs l'éclatement du vote on est
morcelé en autant de l'opinion de chacun
personne n'a les mêmes soucis à
l'intérêt général
c'est d'ailleurs ce qui vous gardez bien
des candidats les candidats ne parle pas
de la france il ne parle pas du projet
de la france ils parlent aux français m
parce qu'elles seraient prêts à rire et
l'autre cas combien le sec exactement
qu'est ce qui change les termes des deux
ne fait pas une unité ça si vous voulez
et saas et d'autres grands problèmes et
je pense que aujourd'hui il faut
absolument retrouver et recouvrer cette
espèce de d'esprit national qu'on a un
peu abandonné vers nation moi je crois
que j'aime pas trop les rations vers
nation là ça revient ça revient un peu à
ça en tout cas une communauté politique
le sentiment d'appartenance d'un destin
commun c'est simplement ce que j'allais
dire ce qui fait nation en france c le
projet politique est d'ailleurs en les
enquêtes ont montré que les pansements
était plutôt intéressés par cette
campagne plus qu'en 2017 si j'en crois
les sondages c'est le fait qu'il n'ait
pas voter c'est peut-être qu'ils n'ont
pas trouvé leur compte dans les
propositions politiques qui n'ont pas
été assez saillantes moi je pense que
emmanuel macron ne faisons pas campagne
au premier tour n'a pas aidé à cette
clarification politique sur les projets
mais ce qu'aujourd'hui lundi au moins
coûté peut-être qu'ils étaient médiocres
en tout cas ça toute la gamme les
enquêtes qui montrent qu'ils sont très
amers après cette préparation et qu'elle
n'est pas au froid à la hauteur on sent
qu'elle peut laisser des traces créer
des frustrations peut-être même des
répliques dans la rue ou les majeures
les gens avaient on attendait quelque
chose et il avait envie de politique et
je crois que la france a envie de
politique est en berne la désaffection
des urnes le désintérêt voire le rejet
la colère en restant chez soi ça existe
aussi en allemagne on en est au même
mobilisa existe en allemagne comme je
vous ai dit les gens ont quand même
l'impression et pas seulement
l'impression que leur vote sert à
quelque chose nous quand on allait
bundestag varennes enfin quand on élit
là le chancelier ou la chancelière vous
avez deux votes vous votez avec votre
première vote pour les pour les députés
du parlement et avec le deuxième non pas
pour la personne du chancellier la
chancelière mais pour le parti qui va
ensuite voté le chancelier ou la
chancelière qui a été nommé avant mais
donc même si vous n'avez pas le
chancelier ou la chance de dire que vous
vouliez avoir vous avez fait augmenter
votre député et même si vous avez par
exemple voté pour dix ans la ftp qui a
eu 11 5% la dernière fois maintenant que
les libéraux c'est en 5 pour ça on
pourrait dire que c'est pas beaucoup ils
ont quatre ministres au gouvernement
grâce à la coalition ils ont je suis
incapable maintenant le nombre de
députés mais c'est aussi conséquent
parlement donc même si vous n'êtes pas
arrivé en première place il y a la
chance est au fait qu'il ya des
coalitions et qui a une autre
représentation au parlement que votre
voix est
représenté et il n'a pas été donné pour
rien donc je crois que ça c'est un
change enfin cette inutilité du buzz
voilà c'est ça oui oui mais enfin il
faut qu'il manque une cohérence au
niveau gouvernemental mental nous on
peuvent difficilement faire cohabiter
dans un même gouvernement des gens
d'extrême gauche et des gens d'extrême
droite ils n'ont rien à voir entre eux
ils n'ont pas du tout la même politique
donc non moi ce que je veux ce que
j'espère c'est qu'il va y avoir si vous
voulez le déjà macron est arrivé à faire
disparaître un à un système politique
était en fait caduque depuis longtemps
puisque le système des essuie glaces qui
faisaient qu'à chaque élection générale
depuis 1981 de 1981 jusqu'à ce que mc on
soit élu la gauche a choisi le rpr a
chassé les ps2 psg leur père ça veut
dire que pour vous c'est tripartisme il
va être père ainsi la recompositions
tout ce stade je le crois je crois
surtout que la démocratie parlementaire
libérale telle que celle que nous avons
connue jusqu'à présent est un peu en
bout de course parce qu'on voit que
c'est dans d'autres pays la montée des
populismes telle qu'on observe avec le
brésil tout avec le laissions de trump
ou ball sonar au mode mode mordin modri
est modifié et les autres montrent
qu'effectivement il ya une espèce de
désenchantement à l'égard de démocratie
qui se traduit pour le moment par un
phénomène extrêmement inquiétant qui
l'appelle à l'homme fort dans tous ces
pays on voit l'homme fort et puis on
voit que poutine incarne un il est las
un contre modèle et que jean ping en
incarne un autre on a affaire quand même
à une crise générale de la démocratie
représentative
on en est là aussi en france et en
france ont quand même être revitalisé
aussi par plus de démocratie
participative d'ailleurs emmanuel macron
a fait quelques tentatives à mon avis
ils n'aboutissent le grand débat n'a
quand même pas complètement été un débat
là il promet s'il est élu des
référendums du mans et de et de
participer d'avoir des vrais conférence
de presse ou d'avoir de vrais interview
vous d'avoir des débats ont une méthode
avec une grande commission un peu tes
odieux
mais ceci étant ce que je crois c'est
que le coeur de refaire société c'est
que cette vie politique sous
n'interviennent pas tous les cinq ans au
risque d'être déçu d'attendre au trot de
cette élection et finalement de ne pas
atteindre l'objet c'est un peu le
problème français de la présidentielle
s'il ya aussi un phénomène qu'il faut
souligner c'est qu'on a une un personnel
politique dont le niveau baisse
énormément il faut parler de ça quand
vous alliez une affiche qui est proposée
puisque valérie giscard d'estaing à
françois mitterrand c'était quand même
autre chose que les quelques uns qui se
sont présentées il y en a pas beaucoup
qui était digne de figurer dans l'es12
l'a1 donc c'est quand même aussi un
problème ça moi je sais ce sont des gens
qui ne sont pas tous dans mon niveau
du niveau d'un homme d'état ou du temps
mais s'y ajoute le problème aussi que
après les élections de 2017 le paysage
politique en france est toujours en
pleine reconstruction
ça s'est jamais enfin les partis ne sont
pas reconstruit donc quand on regarde
les républicains et les socialistes on a
bien la preuve avec les pourcentages et
donc quand il ya quand c'est quand c'est
pas abouti quand ils sont en train de se
chercher on a bien vu que les deux n'ont
pas de deux lignes claires une
proposition un projet est d'ailleurs y
avait aucun projet pendant cette
campagne en 2007 il y avait le projet
demain il a fait rêver il y avait un
coup de magie joignez à briscoe terrier
la zone de nouveau à manque de
l'invasion il n'y a pas un projet commun
pour nous dire alors il va il n'y a pas
sur les jeux et des hanches je crois
qu'il y a
il y avait une déception ou frustration
là aussi et puis il ya autre chose qui
me frappe toujours en france c'est que
les français attendent toujours
tellement de choses de leur état c'est à
dire quand en allemagne évidemment on
attend aussi un mais mais c'est dès que
quelque chose ne va pas dès que le
salaire est et pas assez haut on fait
appel à l'état c'est une attitude
qui n'est pas du tout la même en
allemagne en allemagne les gens en
comment dire une responsable ils
ressentent une responsabilité plus aussi
chez eux pour la propre vie allant de
fête pour leur environnement il ne vient
pas c'est dans cette attente que l'état
doit tout gérer tout corriger la nounou
on a dit pendant la cruciale hiver lors
justement pour terminer ce débat je vais
vous proposer un regard européen sur la
campagne comment vos confrères brita
sundberg non comprises est traité dans
leurs colonnes ces dernières semaines
mon duel avec les os
certains avaient prédit un débat au goût
de tisane il n'en a rien été pour le
quotidien bruxellois le soir les deux
finalistes ne se sont pas épargnés un
débat musclé et très suivi en belgique
près de 400 mille téléspectateurs pour
la rtbf il fallait laver l'affront de
2017 pour l'une éviter l'arrogance pour
l'autre elle est apparue moins agressif
qu'il y a cinq ans mais plus
approximative que son adversaire lui
malgré son ton professoral a été
meilleur sur le fond est plus clair il a
mieux maîtrisé l'exercice comme il ya
cinq ans les médias européens
reconnaissent à l'image du journal el
país en espagne que marine le pen a fait
une meilleure performance qu'il ya cinq
ans le quotidien anglais le guardian en
convient le pen était cette fois ci
beaucoup mieux préparé on lui avait
conseillé d'endosser les habits de mère
de la nation un conseil qu'elle avait
refusé d'écouter en 2017 mais ces mêmes
médias donnent pourtant l'avantagent à
emmanuel macron un débatteur pointu
parfois trop arrogant le journal italien
corriere della serra donne même des
notes aux deux débatteurs meilleur en
argumentation en langage aussi emmanuel
macron est apparu moins empathique que
marine le pen écrit le quotidien avec
une image de président des privilégiés
quand la candidate du rassemblement
national prenez soin de rassurer plutôt
qu'agresser d'agir en mer ou plutôt
entente protectrice et fiable nos
voisins suisses du journal le temps ont
regardé le débat avec cinq jeunes
représentants politiques ce qui m'a
marqué c'est marine le pen c'est
vraiment son calme sa préparation des
candidats étaient davantage dans les
changes que dans l'invectivé ce qui nous
surprend les français en réalité
beaucoup des médias européens constatent
une banalisation de l'extrême droite
dans cette fin de campagne la candidate
du rassemblement national a réussi cette
performance aujourd'hui d'apparaître
beaucoup plus consensuel certains disent
même chirac ise pour emmanuel macron
tout le jeu va donc consister à prouver
qu'elle n'est pas en mesure de gouverner
la france qu'elle ne peut pas être
présidente de tous les français et que
son programme reste seul d'un parti
d'extrême droite une banalisation qui
inquiète nos voisins européens
au point que dans une longue tribune les
chefs de gouvernement allemand portugais
et espagnols l'ont c'est un appel commun
à soutenir et voter emmanuel macron un
appel relayé par les télévisions
allemandes
l'europe a besoin d'un président
français qui soutient les valeurs
et espagnol il parle de la france comme
un repaire de démocratie et de
fraternité pour l'europe et le monde
voilà pour l'opinion de ces trois chefs
de gouvernement mais il faudra attendre
dimanche prochain pouvoir dans les urnes
ce que pense la société française
brita sundberg pour conclure ce débat si
on se projette si marine le pen remporté
dimanche le couple franco-allemand
explose en vol
c'est pas s'il va exploser mais je vois
très noir gta sa conférence de presse
sur la diplomatie la politique étrangère
et j'avais l'impression que la plus
critique et l'allemagne lors de cette
conférence de presse que la russie et
elle a dit qu'elle veut mettre fin un
plein de projets politiques vallée seule
qu'elle continue éventuellement qu'il
continuerait éventuellement se serait de
l'ordre culturel ou économique
et si macron gagne là c'est le moteur
renforcé où c'est plus compliqué non
c'est pas compliqué moi je crois que les
allemands il ya 2 après la crise et vu
que la situation de l'ukraine il ya
maintenant un besoin et une nécessité et
une volonté aussi de faire avancer cette
europe dont emmanuel macron parle depuis
longtemps et on a un chancelier qui a un
programme aussi qui va dans ce sens donc
c'est sûr que les allemands seraient
très rassuré et cette exceptionnelle
quand même que olaf scholz écrit c'est
la tribune et dans une recommandation
s'est jamais laissé les choses comme
elle est très très rapidement un petit
pronostic pour terminer c'est pas très
difficile mais je vais vous demander de
vous mouiller un peu et puis peut-être
la grande leçon aussi de cette campagne
c'est parce qu'elle sait chira qu'ils
espéraient richard vers lima rennes ne
pas être banalisé normalisé un fou
d'elle et oui c'est sûr que c'est pas
son père et c'est un peu cher' acquise
et c'est sur moi je pense que là le
geste premier geste de emmanuel macron
s'il est réélu et je pense qu'il sera
réélu c'est de dire
la fiole ce nous partons pour kiev c'est
évident que ça va être dès la semaine
prochaine être le cas earl jones qui a
radicalement changé quand même la
situation militaire avec la majorité
enfin avec sa coalition de l'allemagne
depuis qu'il est à la chancellerie 4ème
très court oui elle s'est banalisé c'est
assez inquiétant parce qu'en fait de ce
fait elle peut se peut constituer un
groupe le bas contre le haut et j'étais
je disais à yves tout à l'heure qu'est
ce qui s'était passé en 2005 tous ces
appels des revues des journaux des
présidents etc moi ça m'inquiète parce
que ça donne un peu l'impression d'avoir
tout lé les puissants qui viennent au
secours des manuels macron et que du
coup ça peut renforcer moi je trouve ça
penser que le front républicain
je pense qu'elle est contre-productif
contre-productive d'ailleurs expriment
de cette manière c'est dire comme ça des
% seulement y croit encore moi je suis
et des français cette raison que
l'argumentation pour voter pour emmanuel
macron joue simplement sur le ressort de
on maintient l'existant je crois que
c'est fait merci le mot de la fin brice
couturier je me souviens que mon
regretté ami laurent bouvet parlait de
la gauche caviar la gauche castor celle
qui fait des barrages et 10 et que
c'était une très mauvaise idée c'était
une façon de faire monter en fait le
front national le fonctionnent l'euro
semblant de sienne n'a pas changé marine
le pen est toujours la même c'est un
même danger pour la république merci
infiniment j'espère que vos expertises
vos d'analysé de roue ce qui nous ont
regardés à faire leur choix n'oubliez
pas d'aller voter dimanche merci à tous
les quatre on va accueillir à présent
notre grand témoin il a organisé
l'évacuation des civils français
d'afghanistan et de son équipe à
l'ambassade juste avant la prise du
pouvoir des talibans c'était une
exfiltration in extremis au péril de sa
vie qu'il raconte heure par heure dans
son dernier livre c'est l'ambassadeur de
france en afghanistan un poste qu'il
exerce aujourd'hui évidemment depuis
paris on a plein de questions à poser à
david martinon comme les skis ce sujet
de thibaut enoch regarder
si on vous invite david martinon c'est
que vous revenez du front
d'afghanistan précisément où vous étiez
encore il y a dix mois et où vous avez
assisté à la chute de kaboul et la
reprise en main du pays par l'état libre
david martinon vous êtes haut
fonctionnaire ancien porte-parole de
l'elysée actuellement ambassadeur de
france en afghanistan poste que vous
occupez à paris depuis huit mois après
trente trois mois passés à kaboul dans
un livre vous racontez ces heures de
l'été 2000 21 ou la capitale afghane
tombe aux mains des talibans des heures
que vous vivez de l'intérieur avec vos
équipes vous expliquent très 2008 105
personnes en quelques semaines des
français en premier lieu mais aussi des
afghans qui se pressent aux portes de
l'ambassade et la question qu'on se pose
dans ces moments là et la réponse
devient tout de suite c'est est-ce que
franchement je pourrais vivre avec le
lead et le souvenir que des gens des
bébés en particulier aurait pu mourir
contre le portail fermé dans la salle
écrasé par la réponse les ailes gens
immédiatement la suite se passe à
l'aéroport de kaboul vous organisez le
pont aérien 28 vols en dix jours in
extremis vous éviter le pire le 26 août
un attentat suicide fait 173 morts à
l'une des entrées l'aéroport là où
quelques heures plus tôt vous évacuer
nos derniers ressortissants
depuis david martinon le pays s'enfonce
dans la crise financière humanitaire
alimentaire les talibans revenu au
pouvoir non pas tant changé qu'il
voulait le faire croire fin mars le
régime décide de revenir sur sa décision
de permettre aux jeunes filles d'étudier
au lycée et au collège c'est une
décision qui est autant moralement
condamnable que conomique on absurde
au moment où les talibans font face à
une situation humanitaire qui est
extrêmement dégradée il envoie au monde
le signal que la priorité pour eux c'est
quand même de maintenir l'oppression des
femmes se sort des femmes illustres
celui du pays une chape de plomb est
retombé exclu de nombreux emplois
publics contrôlés vestimentairement
interdites de voyager si elles ne sont
pas accompagnées d'un homme de leur
famille les femmes afghanes souffrent
certaines résistent courageusement
manifestent sont arrêtés
alors david martinon partager avec nous
votre expérience vous qui avez négocié
avec eux les talibans peuvent ils
changer
y at il un espoir pour les femmes
afghanes kaboul reverra t elle un jour
la liberté
bonsoir david martinon merci d'être là
les quinze jours qui ont fait basculer
kaboul c'est à dire aux édition de
l'observatoire c'est un récit heure par
heure haletant et en même temps très
personnelle tout s'est passé in extremis
le 15 août 2021 juste avant que
l'établît talibans n'envahissent le
quartier de l'ambassade on se souvient
tous des images à ce moment là vous avez
déjà été et 10 portés on va revenir sur
cette scène importante vous auriez pu
rester déjà il faut le dire à votre
arrivée à paris le directeur de cabinet
du ministre des affaires étrangères vous
dit vous êtes des miraculés vous et la
petite équipe de l'ambassade qui est
resté jusqu'au bout vous y repensez à
cette scène souvent
pas tant que ça mais c'est vrai quand on
fait le retour d'expérience il ya eu des
moments de grand risque sur ces 15 jours
mais aussi sur les trois les trente
trois mois que j'ai passés à kaboul il
ya eu d'autres moments en fait le la
menace terroriste elle est présente à
peu près à chaque instant à kaboul sous
différentes formes que ce soit les
menaces d'explosion la menace d'
attaques complexes est-ce qu'on se
prépare ce que vous racontez qu'il y
avait les plans vous aviez anticiper une
chute de kaboul après le départ des
derniers soldats américains il y avait
quelque chose d'opérationnel qui étaient
déjà mises en place oui on est parti de
ce constat fin de cette analyse que le
scénario probable pour nous à
l'ambassade de france était celui d'une
victoire complète et rapide des talibans
après le départ des derniers soldats
étrangers et avec un timing qu'on avait
assez bien vu puisque le délai le plus
court pour nous c'était 45 jours et de
fait ça à était 45 jours et donc ça nous
a laissé 14 mois pour nous préparer ce
que nous avons fait et donc nous sommes
arrivés en effet une planification de
sécurité qui était assez précises avec
des options mais j'insiste là dessus
c'est pas parce que vous êtes préparés
vous êtes prêt en réalité c'est la règle
de toutes les crises la préparation vous
donne une agilité qui vous permettrait
aux imprévus il ya toujours des
intrigues justement l'imprévu c'est au
moment où il faut évacuer il ya une
atmosphère de grande confusion là vous
êtes déjà partis mais vous prenez une
décision très importante et il faut la
prendre extrêmement vite vous êtes déjà
vers l'aéroport héliporté c'est la
bousculade et l'affolement devant les
grilles de l'ambassade où la population
se précipitent il ya des femmes et à des
enfants qui risquent d'être écrasés sur
sur les grilles de l'ambassade
ça pas prévu c'est contraire au
protocole qu'est-ce que vous décidez le
fait est que vous voyez ces images qui
avait c'était le moment où les taliban
entraient
dans la zone sécurisée donc là vous
voyez l'ambassade de france je sais pas
si les téléspectateurs le voit mais tout
ça crée un peu plus loin vous avez
l'entrée du palais présidentiel un peu
plus loin vous avez la base de
l'ancienne base de l'otan d'où je venais
de décoller et les talibans étaient en
train d'entrer avec leurs pick up blindé
avec leurs mitrailleuses leurs armes
dans tous les sens il y avait des tirs
de grenades y avait des tirs tout court
il venait de devises et les hélicoptères
qui suivait la noria qui nous a emmenés
moi et mon équipe et donc il ya eu ce
moment de en effet de très grande
confusion où vous aviez une foule de
gens qui voulaient absolument être mis
en sécurité par l'ambassade de france
qui se pressait devant le portail fermé
j'ai en effet donné l'instruction de
qu'il soit ouvert parce que je ne
pouvais pas imaginer que des gens
meurent contre le point comme entrant
cette décision là on aurait dit qu'est
ce que vous pouvez avoir des morts sur
la conscience et en même temps ça peut
être très risqué oui c'est une prise de
risques parce que à ce moment là j'ai
en réalité nous aurions dû tous partir
de l'ambassade de france il devait y
avoir encore une rotation ou deux pour
l'équipe qui restaient derrière sauf que
c'est devenu impossible on ne peut plus
sortir ni par hélicoptères ni par la
route et donc le fait de rouvrir
l'ambassade de france
créer un point de fixation à l'arrière
est donc un problème qu'à ce moment là
je ne savais pas du tout comment
négocier avec les talibans pour évacuer
ces personnes qui s'étaient réfugiés à
l'intérieur de l'ambassade et là il ya
une autre opération avec des bus avec le
raid avec une couverture aérienne
américaine racontez-nous ce qui se passe
parce que à un moment donné il ya
l'arrestation des bus les talibans avec
des tirs de sommation expliquez-nous
nous craignons une prise d'otages on a
pris on a en effet craint une prise
d'otages massives on a craint un piège
on a craint la désorganisation puisque
des contacts avaient été pris
par le commandant ben hida qui était à
l'époque à l'ambassade avec le chef
taleb du checkpoint à côté il ya eu
d'autres contacts ont été pris c'était
une désorganisation totale du côté du
côté des talibans s'étaient des
combattants qui venait d'arriver y avait
pas encore de tête politique donc des
gens avec qui on aurait pu négocier
quelque chose de très cadrée et donc ce
qu on a craint c'est que la sécurité de
ce cortège ne soit pas assurée jusqu'à
l'aéroport et de fait il ya eu beaucoup
de confusion il ya eu cette check polt
est en effet un des premiers de chaque
poule tu as été le lieu d'une d'une
longue négociation difficile avec en
effet des tirs de coups de feu qui
heureusement ont été faits en ont été
tirés en bas de cortège et donc les
policiers qui étaient en début de
cortège ne les ont pas entendus dans la
confusion ce qui a fait que au final
chacun est resté sur son sur son quant à
soi il y avait discernement ils ont ils
ont très bien géré la situation il ya eu
28 vols en dix jours c'est sont des
français qui vivent en afghanistan
évidemment les personnels de l'ambassade
les afghans aussi qui ont aidé la france
à c'était la mission de la france devait
de les sauver il ya eu à plusieurs
reprises plaints de catastrophes qui ont
été évités de justesse vous raconter
tout ça c'était qui ce petit noyau dur
de diplomate pour qu'ils vous écrivez
vous leur rendez hommage dans le livre
qui restait jusqu'au bout comment ça
s'est décidé au fond de rester comme ça
at elle des irréductibles dans ce pays
d'à ce mois là
c'était de toute façon une fois qu'on
était à l'aéroport la mission avait
changé nous avions déjà mis en sécurité
les employés afghans de l'ambassade de
france bien avant la chute de kaboul
mais à ce moment là assez naturellement
en réalité on s'est dit qu'il fallait
continuer à sortir des afghans en danger
que nous nous connaissions et donc
c'était important que les diplomates qui
avait l'habitude de traiter avec
certains qui nous aidaient soient
présents ne serait ce que pour les
identifier au téléphone pour les guider
dans la foule pour aller les reconnaître
et donc en effet autour de moi j'avais
mon numéro 2 j'avais un conseiller
politique j'avais le conseiller de
coopération culturelle voyez j'avais mon
escorte du ray javed les gardes de
sécurité diplomatique des policiers
j'avais un peu dgse et j'avais nous ont
rejoint des militaires du commandement
des opérations spéciales on va parler de
la situation dans le pays aujourd'hui
des images qu'on a vu de ses filles est
en larmes qui n'ont pas pu aller à
l'école en fait les écoles dans le
secondaire elles ont ouvert quelques
minutes du fief également et dont elles
ont refermé les talibans finalement
c'est l'oppression des femmes qui les
obsède c'est ça leur priorité
c'est ce qu'il prouve tous les jours en
réalité puisque la situation humanitaire
est très dégradée en afghanistan
néanmoins ce qui semble prioritaire pour
eux c'est en effet de maintenir la
pression des femmes c'est consternant
c'est moralement condamnable c'est
économiquement totalement stupide
puisqu'on il n'y a aucune chance qu'on
développe un pays en se privant de 50 %
de sa population c'est un moment au
début qu'il avait un peu changé que
c'était plus les mêmes tient 20 ans
qu'il existait même une frange
réformiste chez les talibans ça n'est
pas du tout le cas alors pour ma part
j'ai jamais cru je pense que le concept
de talibans modérés n'existe pas en
revanche ce qui est vrai c'est que
certains ont plus apparaître plus
pragmatique que d'autres et pour cela le
pragmatisme c'est l'expression du fait
qu'ils ont conscience qu'ils ont besoin
de la communauté internationale et
qu'ils doivent donc savoir quoi dire à
leurs partenaires internationaux
interlocuteurs internationaux et donc
sont des stratèges certes certains sont
des stratèges mais le fait est que pour
le moment les décisions de ce régime
sont particulièrement compteront donc
l'avenir du pays pour le moins sombre
l'actualité c'est aussi des des
centaines de milliers de réfugiés qui
arrivent en france notamment dans
d'autres pays on a plusieurs millions
qui fut de craine quand vous voyez qu'on
a activé une une directive européenne
pour eux pour les réfugiés ukrainien qui
a aussi des centaines de réfugiés
afghans qui sont par de pantin dans des
tentes comment vous réagissez il n'y a
pas deux poids deux mesures non je
trouve pas parce que en l'occurrence la
fin je parle pour la france mais je vois
aussi
et collègues ont fait à kaboul la
solidarité nationale elle s'est
organisée immédiatement
elles avaient été les mécanismes
français ont été érodées pendant des
semaines puisque encore une fois nous
avions déjà évacué plus de 650 personnes
femmes et enfants
et la réalité c'est que les afghans ont
été accueillis dans toute la france il
ya un effort de solidarité qui s'est vu
tout de suite langnau d'hébergement
c'est à moi je reçois des propositions
de familles d'accueil qui se propose
comme ça d'accueillir des avants donc
non je pense pas qu'il y ait eu deux
poids deux mesures et sur place en
afghanistan est ce qu une résistance
aussi infime soit elle est possible
disons que
souhaiteront pas la poursuite de la
guerre c'est très difficile à dire mais
les afghans eux-mêmes sorte de 42 ans de
guerre
chacun aspire à la paix en afghanistan
néanmoins le fait est que si le pouvoir
taliban ne comprend pas qu'il se doit
d'être inclusif et qu'il se doit de
représenter toutes les minorités les
groupes ethniques alors alors
la recette en afghanistan c'est si on
est frustré si on n'a pas une part de
pouvoir ou prendre les armes et c'est
très probablement ce que je voulais dire
c'est que
voilà cette gouvernance talopp c'est une
recette pour un nouveau désastre merci
beaucoup merci infiniment d'aller mater
loin d'être passée sur le plateau de lcp
les quinze jours qui ont fait basculer
kaboul c'est à dire aux édition de
l'observatoire merci à vous de nous
avoir suivis c'est la fin de cette
émission votre soirée documentaire
commence tout de suite avec jean-pierre
grâce à ce soir z zone d'education
documentaire pardonnez moi ces magazines
de valérie brochard elle me pardonnera
très bon week end reposez vous bien et à
la fois prochaine
[Musique]